[موسيقى]
طلعني اخي
بعدين شو اسمه
جابولي ابني قالوا لي عايش تروح انت ضل لي
واحد تروح انت
[موسيقى]
بقى صلاه الفجر قالوا
شو بدي أصير اكتر من هيك يا عمي شو بده
يصير
اولادي وشو بده يصير اكثر
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ضليت كم ساعه ايه بعدين سكتت اشهدت اخر
نفس واحد لحتى سمعني صنادي اخواتي يطلعوني
بس انا شايفه جوزي تحت السقف في اولاد جسس
فوقي
[موسيقى]
في اولاد كتير فوقي كانوا
فتحنا الباب ركدناه هو ماسك ابني الصغير
انا شفت قدامي بنت فكرتها بنتي طلعت بنت
الجاره اولادي يضلوا بالبيت
وصلت عالدرجه تحت قلبت فينا البنايه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
تجربه كتير والله يعني شو بدي اعيد يعني
ورجعنا لهلا صار هالزلزال كل شي يعني
رجعنا هلا شلون طلعنا من الشام
مثل هيك ما جينا باوعينا وهلا نحن باوعينا
ما في شيء
[موسيقى]
لهلا بحس حالي لسه ما طلعت
كل ما بدي اقعد او شي احس لساتني انا تحت
ما طلعت